it is gutsy to ask him you know he's
kind of washed up i mean i wouldn't say
it is injuries that were the issue but
something happened in 2020 that was not
related to injuries that's the great
mystery with carson wentz yeah he got
injured in 2017 when he was on track to
be the nfl mvp yeah 2018 he was still
getting over that and then he had the
back problem 2019. he he was great he
was the only guy that was healthy down
the stretch he took the eagles from five
and seven to nine and seven they got in
the playoffs and he had the illegal hit
from genevieve and clowney there was
neither flag nor fine that gave him a
concussion um
but last year he was healthy and it all
fall apart so that's the great mystery
for the colts before they get caught up
in all this and jim irsay the owner of
the team what a surprise he's already
super optimistic about the team under
carson wentz you got to figure out
what happened last year
whether it was a fluke or whether this
is just where he is
in his football career after five years
in the nfl miles
well i i think it's great that he feels
comfortable with frank wright and i
think it's great that he is trying to
focus on everything going forward and
all that but i think at the same time
it's impossible basically to ignore what
he did and how badly that he looked in
last year's games and i just look at the
sac numbers because
yes a lot of times we put sacks
on the offensive line and we always talk
about pass protection and pass
protection has to get better and all
that but he was sacked seven or more
times thrice not once not twice thrice
how does that happen and how do you then
say i'm going to magically get better at
going through my progressions and not
holding on to the ball that that's weird
it's why he was sacked 50 times in only
12 games and deshawn watson was sacked
49 times and that only happened then
that happened in 16 it was sacked once
more per game that's a lot that's on
carson wentz and i just i don't know
that anything is magically going to
solve that just by going to a head coach
you're comfortable with
reich was the offensive coordinator in
philly when wentz played his best
football here's wentz from yesterday
talking about that reunion you mentioned
with frank reich
getting to work with him for two years
and
uh not just the personal side of things
which we knew we you know we had a great
relationship with that but the x's and
those of football and how we see the
game and how we
can kind of have healthy discussions and
disagreements but really challenge each
other and
ultimately make each other better it was
it was a lot of fun and uh you know i
look forward that you know that's
something i'm super excited about
getting to work with him again because i
have the utmost respect for for the man
that he is um you know the friend that
he's been for to me as well but also the
coach that he is as well
when it was clear things were falling
apart for once in philadelphia
indianapolis was the only play and
really if the eagles didn't have
indianapolis and frank right there i
don't know what they would have gotten
for carson wentz would they have had to
have done a brock osweiler hot potato
trade where you give up net trade assets
to get the contract off your roster they
may have had to do that and and i can't
help but wonder miles whether to some
extent
when things began to fracture in philly
once
specifically
concluded at some level
i want to get back with frank reich and
philip rivers
he's the quarterback now he goes after
this year i slide into indianapolis
i i
as as a human being at some point over
the course of the 2020 season i don't
think it's unreasonable to think carson
wentz
had that idea had that notion and
ultimately that aspiration to get a
reunion with frank wright
no of course and that's why i think he
said in that presser that it was about
the green bay game when he was benched
that he felt like that's when he knew it
probably wasn't going to work in
philadelphia for him and i mean
i guess it took him that long but okay
and if it's at that point then you're
like man where else could i go
maybe have some success hmm you know i
look around the league where are the
guys that i'm comfortable with the only
conclusion has to be indianapolis
because it's somebody that you worked
with and somebody who you feel like
brought the best out of you and i guess
the only thing was well is philip rivers
going to be there or not going forward
and so probably when philip rivers
retired and announced that retirement so
soon after the 2020 season
carson wentz's eyes probably just lit up
and his ears probably perked up and he
was like wow if i can get myself there
then then i can probably really
resurrect my career in a way that's
going to be beneficial for everybody so
it's worked out for him so far let's see
if it works out for him on the field
because that's really i think where the
true test is going to be
and and one thing we know is there's
always something going on behind the
scenes and once frank wright thought
maybe he's going to get
carson wentz
that may have accelerated the retirement
decision of philip rivers if the colts
made it clear they were ready to move on
and this is a better situation for them
long term because it was one more year
max with rivers it's multiple years it's
ten more years potentially with wentz if
they can get this figured out
wence was also asked yesterday whether
or not he specifically requested a trade
from the eagles here's the question with
the answer from carson wentz
are you saying you didn't want to be
traded
i'm not saying one way or another you
know there's a lot of conversations a
lot of things that that kind of shook
out and as it played out you know this
is this is what went down and i'm i'm
excited about it i'll tell you that much
was there a moment carson where you felt
that maybe it just
was your was there was it in green day
like was there just a moment where you
felt like you know what maybe it's just
time for a fresh start was there a
moment
um i mean
green bay was probably the moment that i
realized you know this might not be it
you know when anytime you're pulled you
don't know what's you know what am i
going to go back out next week next
drive like i had no idea um and so all
those things go through your mind but
try and not overthink it you know try
and just be in the moment do what i can
obviously
frustrated and not be playing but at the
same time trying to be there for my
teammates and do everything i can to
help help the team win and
but yeah those thoughts definitely
you know creep in once once you're
benched and that's just how it unfolded
wence has found a way to fashion almost
a clark kent superman type of a
dichotomy here where
he's managed to keep the high road and
never have to say anything that anyone
could criticize him for when it was
obvious during the season miles someone
from the wentz camp was repeatedly
leaking things like the relationship
with doug peterson is fractured beyond
repair carson wentz wants out of
philadelphia carson wentz and frank and
and doug peterson didn't speak for weeks
a claim that still is implausible eight
nine ten weeks how can the quarterback
and the head coach not speak for eight
nine or ten weeks when he was only
benched for the last four weeks of the
season but somebody was stirring it up
with or without wentz's consent
when wence was the guy who never said
anything that was remotely controversial
but it's clear now in hindsight he
wanted out and he got out and now
there's no reason to look backward he
looks forward and let's see if he can be
the guy that the eagles thought he was
when they traded up thought he was early
in his career and thought he was when
they kept him instead of nick foles and
paid carson wentz 33.5 million a year
yeah he kind of reminded me of mark
maguire and that old
congressional hearing you know i'm not
here to talk about the past when he's
just like i don't know what to say if
i'm going to if i requested a trade one
way or the other but look
if this works then it's one of the most
masterful jobs that i think any
quarterback has done when he's in the
middle of a contract to get himself out
of one situation and put himself in
another situation where he thinks he can
be successful and you know it's i think
you're absolutely right it's almost
impossible to think that the coach and
the quarterback weren't speaking how do
you not speak to the coach how does how
does that even work you know how are you
implementing a game plan he's calling
the plays don't you guys have to figure
out something that works for both of you
because that's how you have job security
and i guess that's why both of them both
don't have jobs in philadelphia anymore
so yeah it's it's so it was a bad
situation i think for everybody in
philadelphia and now both of these guys
the team and then carson once himself
they both get fresh starts
and and look it's it's possible that
what shefty meant when he said that on
97.5 the fanatic in philly was they
weren't communicating away from the
field what happens is
you speak one way on tv
when
you are
are fully aware and conscious of the
fact that everything you say can and
will be used against you you get into a
looser more comfortable radio setting
sometimes you're not as buttoned up and
sometimes things come out in a way that
that are easier to scrutinize and
criticize so i always prefer those when
it's someone else and not me uh so i can
scrutinize and criticize but it always
was implausible that they didn't speak
for eight nine or ten weeks but maybe
they just they stopped speaking away
from the meeting room in the practice
field and and the stadiums
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports